well we're filming in a market that's an
ordinary market but they sell a lot of
drugs and weapons from there we've been
working now for a few days to try and
arrange a meeting with one of the gangs
that runs the PTO market which is in
Mexico City so we have to choose what
sort of kit we we take with us it's a
surprisingly small actually nowadays in
fact we shoot on small cameras like this
one and we've got three of them that are
working they take HD picture and a
really good quality in front of matter
is earlier if you lose one of these
which taken off to you or it's broken
it's a few thousand as opposed to and of
our big old cameras which would be tens
of thousands so the equipment itself is
quite small could go into one bag and be
carried
there's tripods and things this is a bag
that ricci a cameraman has with him all
the time but probably will lose that in
the car and he put a cam a monopod as
opposed to a proper tripod because we're
trying to be as low profile as possible
big question of course when you're
filming gangs it's very dangerous
not least because of what they do for a
living the murder rate of course in
Mexico is very very high as well
but also you're not absolutely certain
what they're going to be like because
they can be drinking or on cocaine
certainly we've experienced that so you
have to make a decision do you want to
take another piece of kit which is of
course what we wear all the time in war
zones which is body armor that's
slightly different because it's it's
it's low profile that can actually go
under a coat and be fairly inconspicuous
the reason we're not going to be wearing
this today though is that we're right in
the heart of the gangland so it's not
obviously we don't have a danger from
shrapnel but we would have a danger from
a specific targeted shot but we'd be
overwhelmed there and you couldn't get
out anyway so there's there's really no
reason to get to have this we've been
invited in it is an agreement so
hopefully it should be okay
as I say sure we live dealing with these
type of people you're never absolutely
certain how it's gonna go so we're
coming to film one of the gangs that
sell weapons in Mexico City to the
cartels and to pretty much anyone who
wants them you have to go back into
Pepito market which is the cartels
already told us they don't want us to
come back at the film again but there's
been some negotiation and it seems now
that it's okay but it's a it's slightly
unnerving having to go back when they've
already given us the warning not to come
back but I see how it goes
we'll see we're in a place where they
make DVDs knockoff DVDs it's in the
market down an alleyway and coming to
film the drug the gun gangs rather but
because there's lots of drugs taking
place this DVD machines you're never
quite certain how things are gonna turn
out you're never gonna be quite certain
when they're gonna show up if they're
going to show up what they're going to
bring with them the best sort of well
it's like when you're doing this type of
story not never you can't guarantee
anything okay so that's it the gun gang
have been this will now return to being
an illegal DVD production house once
again will be gone is like we were never
here